a lo largo del mar báltico
los obreros se activan para colocar los
últimos tubos de un gasoducto gigante y
controvertido mil doscientos treinta
kilómetros para transportar gas desde
rusia hasta alemania pero su trazo rodea
a ucrania que teme perderse los dos o
tres mil millones de dólares anuales de
ingreso por el tránsito de gas sobre
todo ucrania teme las consecuencias
geopolíticas más importantes perder la
protección contra una agresión rusa a
gran escala ya que el país todavía está
en guerra contra su vecino en el este el
conflicto con los separatistas apoyados
por moscú ya deja más de 14.000 muertos
y elijan si el gas no pasa a través de
ucrania eso aumenta los riesgos de una
guerra total entre rusia y ucrania y de
una agresión a gran escala contra
ucrania desde rusia
rusia no dudará en bayern a ucrania ya
no solo en el este también en el centro
y el norte
eeuu también del proyecto con malos ojos
donald trump había impuesto sanciones
considerables contra las empresas que
trabajaban en la construcción para
retrasar las obras pero la
administración baiden prefirió
levantarlas y apostar por una
cooperación con alemania favorable al
proyecto a la vez que amenazar a moscú
con represalias en caso de agresiones
desde rusia
es poco probable que las sanciones
impidan que se termine el gasoducto su
construcción
después que esta administración ha
considerado que no nos interesaba
perjudicar y debilitar la relación
bilateral que tenemos con alemania
nuestra aliada
por su lado alemania se comprometió a
presionar para que el gas ruso continúe
transitando por ucrania durante los
próximos años